this is Finn the human so we finally see
what was going on there they they
traveled to whatever the portal of
different dimensions and the Lich wishes
for everything to be destroyed including
himself right doesn't even sort of
disappear too well you see always just
roll for existence to be destroyed or
something to everyone to be destroyed
yeah but since he's in that room that
doesn't count remember and that nobody
disappears because he went back to his
reality
oh okay so but Finn and Jake are kept
safe because they're in this room that
apparently protects them so they're
trying to think of what wish they can
come up with to stop this off from
happening so they wish for the Lich to
not exist and that leads to the reality
was at the end of the last one which is
pretty much the world I guess if the
apocalypse didn't happen um and the Lich
did something that had the apocalypse
happened and they already cleaned it you
never remember what the Lich did yeah no
I don't go on good vintage okay no I'm
sorry I really do forget um there's a
lot to keep up with it's like the
inception of kids shows one movie this
is entirely so it's even worse it's
better so so anyway so so it's a world
where the apocalypse doesn't really
happen at least not the way it did the
other world and magic has not bloomed
and instead it's still kind of science
of technology issue like I said Finn has
robotic arm and everything and he has to
sell his burrow and Jake the dog which
is just a normal dog now goes with them
and they come across who were those guys
supposed to be the bullies or whatever
no one just these bullies that I guess
are there just to make things tough but
choose Bruce is there one right
reminded me of Swiss car yeah their
weird accent thing oh I don't think it
was intentionally that she's crazy
oh yes truth is there and says go up
there and defeat those evil people uh
while also coming across a tent ice king
or dead simon magus yeah i got a chance
to be i ski and a not so good-looking
Marceline obviously not keeping up with
her appearance or anything well she's
not a vampire
yeah well but she had the pointy she
steam all that's right yeah it's the
vampire that makes her loose and stay
young yeah yeah okay yeah okay fair
enough
well live forever in state young yeah so
um so Finn takes the crown think inside
its to having to sell the bro and the
bullies come and take it
he goes to try and take it back but they
bring the talents doing that so they try
to go home but they're burning the house
with his parents to inside did I even
get here
how'd I even get here bro or song though
how did I even get here son which that
was the funniest line well I love it cuz
they're all standing in the window and
it looks just like a little picture yeah
there you've been holding the kid and
it's like you're just a guess huh and
then Finn puts the crown on and
Marceline says Make A Wish make a wish
and so uh he does and it anything um I
had to say I thought this would be
better I and I love parallel dimension
stuff I love seeing what different
characters look like and where they're
at and what I like the um know once
you've got the Fionna and cake I love
that one I wanted to see what everybody
looked like I thought this world very
boring and I I serve a like okay just
sort of general bullies and the
backstory was interesting so I can't
because I forgot what happens with the
Lich but you know it's neat to see a
different sort of point of view and yeah
world where it's like I do like that
lesson where you think well yeah this
will obviously fix everything if this
one person never existed
it's you think about what an impact even
if it is a bad one that kids still have
I mean it's still good in fact it can
still change things whether it be for
better or worse and you know so the
causality stuff you know I like those
ideas I like the silver even the tiniest
thing can have a huge impact um but yeah
I just I couldn't get into a world I
couldn't get into most of the characters
in it yeah with the exception of Simon
yelling at Marceline which is pretty
funny or what if she's even really
hearing it and then the two spruce and
then the the bully is saying I don't
even like I didn't laugh that much I
wasn't it would being such at the
flashback I wasn't that drawn in and
yeah now I'm just curious what the next
one is you know like okay well we have
that I hope the next one's very
different from this so how about you I
feel like part of it being boring you
know in a sense might have been a little
bit on purpose because this show is not
a game this is exactly what it's like
without the witch I mean this is what
normal life is they would be normal in a
sense and here you go this is what
happens you know again it's that idea of
good and bad they coexist everything
kind of has a purpose whether it's good
or not I mean you know it's this weird
if a then B plus okay but even with that
even with that said it isn't her we've
all seen stuff where people or scenarios
are supposed to be boring but they're
still funny in out boring they are you
know could be something with that I mean
these are really good writers I mean
these are good people that know all
sorts of different kinds of comedy and
delivery and stuff and it's just if that
was really the intention and I think
they're kind of right they don't want to
look at as magical as cool as the Candy
Kingdom but could they kind of get a
little funnier I don't think that's it I
think the problem is with us I think the
problem part of the problem is oh yeah
it's all you you know what you are you
us
I am uh no part of the problem is with
us you're so used to Finn you one thing
you want your Finn
who is this Finn I mean it's interesting
cuz we want to know what this Finn is
all about but really I want my friend I
mean I don't know part of it but Finn
seemed the same everything else is what
seemed different me if it seemed fine
you know oh I don't know for me it was
like I love my Finn like this Finn is
okay and I'm interested how the hell did
he get that arm how is this happening
but really I want my friend
I want my world back that we had so much
time to grow to love and get used to you
make sense of it
oh I didn't like this
if this episode happened in the middle
of a season I think I would have liked
it the fact that it's the season
premiere yeah
what's kind of a kick in the pants yeah
it kind of didn't even kick it didn't
even spark me like yeah this is like
what people have been waiting for like
whatever a year or something to see it
it's kind of like yeah after the ending
of last the last episode after just
everything that happened in that last
episode where I was just so like oh my
god in a sense how much further can they
go where can they go with this they go
here yeah it's like it's a good setup
it's a it's a great setup but then they
go here and intentional or not to me a
fail as a fail and it you can take
average everyday life every day world
every post-apocalyptic or whatever and
still make it interesting look at Mad
Max or Mad Max Beyond road warrior happy
I found it done with these can we get
over or can we get beyond Thunder no
sorry I've failed that once this is um
but no like road warrior Mad Max that's
the future but and it's dude supposed
apocalyptic and all that stuff but
and it's barren but it's still
interesting just the way they do in the
in uh normal go to court venture time
you have stop signs and and destroyed
cars and all that stuff just kind of
like all over the place like oh yeah
this stuff was here did this place have
a cleaning crew yeah I mean it's I was
trying to I couldn't get a feel for the
world or what it was yeah I didn't even
you said rode away or I mean it's like
I'm like I think I do doing this with a
little bit of a needle
medieval touch kinda it's hard for me to
get sort of a grasp on it oh man I
really did yeah I did feel a little bit
medieval e-type yeah wits and the you
know yeah it was weird the land of oh no
no I'm not really gonna be bad for you
that's okay but this is a new anymore
yeah I mean but for those the Land of
Ooo I mean like did sound funny to say
it definitely had this this identity not
that it was just you know really happy
goofy you know candy kingdoms and stuff
like that but that there were different
parts and that it was built on top of
this apocalypse
ya know you can't really it's like even
you don't want to show what you know
almost up to the apocalypse you know
whatever but where everything's sort of
evolved from and how we got there and
stuff I mean it's just sort of if it is
there it's just not interesting yeah and
it just it just looked like since there
was no actual apocalypse and all of that
stuff but where's the cars where's the
debris the stuff doesn't instantaneously
just disappear you know you have to have
it somewhere and I saw no signs of the
pest I guess you could say and that was
kind of like well I mean I mean I'm
thinking like maybe they got like what
are some of the shades are kind of 80s
those like oh they source ground
whatever they found that like again
bring a runway or again uh you could see
all the stuff that they scrounge
together and they put together yeah you
know and it sort of became this new
identity yeah that the world created um
and yeah you know and I'll say myself
maybe this will be like
whatever the the Christmas episode where
it's like the first episode it's like
okay I hope it's building there's
something and that's like holy smokes
what a payoff that was unbelievable um
but I don't it's sounding like it isn't
but I'll wait for because it isn't be
continued I'll wait to see but yeah I
don't know it had to be quite a good
punch line out the gate that can match
the punch line that they have the
Christmas
are you the payoff that's right not the
payoff that they had the Christmas
episode
another thing that bothered me about or
okay one thing that I did like about it
was the whole Simon part hmm but you got
yeah like that happened a minute into
Marceline
if you know Simon didn't turn into the
Ice King yeah you know so Marceline does
not become a vampire and she ages
normally in a sensor won't leave her you
know and she loses her which I love
that um yeah she sort of turns into the
new Ice King in a sense she takes a lot
which is you know I never thought about
the shape yeah you can nailed that even
with the the why the other thing I'll
even say actually I do kind of like
which I so then they do more of you know
like choose Bruce it's like well if this
world didn't exist you choose goose
wouldn't be born our magic I think my
legs are this idea that there's still
some patterns I would still somehow get
going you know and so gets into motion
they were just resulting in certain
people still kind of existing just not
exactly you know that yeah and somehow
actions would still lead to a person
very similar to choose goose you know
coming into existence you know I sort of
every even fit or whatever so I I kind
of like that idea um but I felt they
didn't touch upon that was another that
was one thing that I didn't like and
it's minor and it's a kids show and
people can rag on me all they want to um
Finn's arm I love the concept of him
having an arm and everything one I want
to know how it works it's pretty
interesting and it's a pretty neat
concept the cool thing about ooh is that
anything can happen and you can
make up any kind of excuse of why it
happens this is supposed to seem to be
more down - no pun intended down to
earth and it's supposed to be more
reality-based because there is no magic
so I'm still looking at that mechanical
I'm gonna like how would that even
remotely work how would it be able to
you know close and open and then he just
goes like this and takes it off and
plugs in a you know a knife and it's
like but there has to be some connection
to make it open and close and and why
would you choose burst be making this
knife to begin with why do you have if
I'm right it could be wrong I have seen
some arms that actually I don't know how
they do it something when there is where
they actually can open but that's the
thing that's where you'd attach this to
the armor to the number whatever oh yeah
it goes like that but that's like taking
off the hand
I guess well then again I guess maybe if
you take off the hand and there's the
same attachment but you but even taking
that out of it uh the arm had virtually
no purpose you know and I was really
like like what happened with the arm how
did he lose the arm how did this end
it's it's pretty pointless and what's a
little sore guys it's all that feels
natural even then kind of like do
anything look kinda like peeing outside
it kind of okay I'm pretty much done
well right the right arm
there is more with it later on okay but
at the same time I completely agree with
you at this point in time it's like
there is nothing behind it it's just oh
look this is what's going on later can
we go back to your ask you like use the
show creator here for about the next 12
episode you better be why Oh God